Let's talk, first of all,
you know the Super Bowl's on a lot
of people's minds.
Yes.
We've been talking about
it a lot on the show.
You guys at Saturday Night Live are doing
a Super Bowl Halftime show.
Yes, its a Weekend Update
Halftime Spectacular.
And its, and its...
And its gonna be live.
Now, is there any chance you're going to
do your Liza Minnelli impression?
Because she does an amazing Liza Minnelli.
Ah!
(Conan and audience laughing)
That's her.
Horrible.
That's her long laugh, is that 'Ah!'
It kinda gets stuck.
Right.
Like in her throat.
Right. You're not-
She's busy trying to breathe.
Right, right.
(audience laughing)
Of course, Alan, a good friend of Liza's.
(Conan chuckling)
Huge. She's fantastic.
And she's good.
I've done a duet with Liza.
Did you really?
You did a duet?
Mhm. Yeah we did two-
Was this at the garage?
No, it was proper.
(everyone laughing)
You both needed to get some ice cream.
Kind of.
Yeah.
Now I heard, I don't know if this is true,
but I heard that you're obsessed with
Steve Harvey.
I am.
And I don't know what that means.
Like, you're obsessed,
are you stalking him?
Steve Harvey the comedian.
What is it that you're obsessed with
about Steve Harvey?
I have no idea.
I think he's so amazing looking.
Mhm.
First of all, whenever I see him,
I don't know what it
is, but it fills me with
an immense sense of joy.
(audience laughing)
Like, its, uh-
Just when you see Steve Harvey?
Its like, its like his hairline is perfect
and he's got that amazing mustache.
Uh-huh.
And he just looks like a, um,
a Plastic Black Man Doll.
Right.
I-
We have, I think. Do we have a-
We have a picture here of Steve Harvey.
Really?
Yeah, I just always... Yeah, there he is!
Yeah, okay. I see what you're saying.
(audience clapping)
That makes me crazy.
No, you're- You know what?
You were right. I was
feeling a little down
'cause its so cold out and everything.
I saw that picture - put it up again!
And I felt really good again, you know?
Yeah.
And it filled me with joy.
(audience cheering)
That's terrific.
You know there would be no world war
if our planes just went around the world
dropping leaflets of
that Steve Harvey photo.
War as we know it would
end. Because people
would be like "I hate those Americans!
Ha ha ha Steve Harvey!"
It would really, it would bring the world
to a place of peace
and harmony.
And understanding.
Yeah.
Um,
I like to end that like Batman.
"And understanding."
Now you on Saturday Night Live,
you've been having a good time,
you've been successful. You've had
a lot of successful characters.
Its all going well for you.
Yeah.
But there seems to be a pattern.
It seems like they've pigeonholed you
a little bit in a specific way.
Yeah, I'm usually the
girl that if they need
someone to be half naked, I'll say
"I'll do it."
Right.
And I've sort of been thinking about,
you know, this is my
third season on the show,
so I've been thinking about
"Okay what do I usually do?" And its like,
well I'm usually half naked, um, in an
enormous wig. I'm usually
doing some sort of dance.
And I'm usually making out with people.
I've even noticed that.
You're always the one that's
making out on the show.
Yeah. Yeah, they know
that old Rudolph will
do it. I know.
Is there someone there with a cigar
that's like, "Get Rudolph!"
Get Rudolph on the horn, she'll do it.
Rudolph'll do it!
Its true. I have no
shame, and I will do it.
You've done a lot. We
actually found a, uh,
just a little tribute to
some of the fine work you've done
on Saturday Night Live. Take a look.
Oh, really?
(funky music playing)
(Yeah, yeah)
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
Mm.
I thought that clip was longer.
Yeah.
(audience laughing)
Alright, we're gonna take a little break.
Cool.
Yeah. I hope you're gonna be okay.
(Conan chuckling)